wie ein riesiges wespennest so sieht es
aus wenn sich einmal im jahr tausende
west ii treffen um ihre vespa
leidenschaft zu frönen
dieses jahr im ungarischen zanker 800
seelen dorf am nördlichen ufer des
plattensees wir kommen aus dagegen von
nürnberg der fall muss bukarest
wir wurden in manchester
ich komme aus bali in indonesien ich
komme aus udine in italien einige
teilnehmer haben für die world vespa day
ist eine lange reise auf sich genommen
sowie der vespa club münchen
[Musik]
nach zwei tagen und rund 600 kilometern
sind sie pünktlich zum festival stadt
eingetroffen
für vier tage brummt und knattert es
hier an jeder ecke
die gemeinde der whisky ist groß und
international fahrer aus mehr als 40
ländern sind dieses jahr mit dabei
die motivation ist bei jedem ein anderer
einfach die alte zeit am leben halten
und das ganze genießen die renaissance
der rolle
es ist eine lebensweise man lernt gute
freunde kennen
wir haben viel spaß und auch wichtigsten
ist dass wir diese woche ohne unsere
frauen sind die wespen sind für uns eine
gute gelegenheit europa kennen sondern
wie lange das land die menschen
für mich ist es meine religion meine
leidenschaft ich denke es ist das gefühl
von freiheit mit dem zweitakter auf und
davon
darauf freuen sich hier alle 55
kilometer liegen bei der heutigen tour
vor den 60 rolle
die strecke führt durchs hinterland
entlang kleiner dörfer obstplantagen und
rebstöcken der weinanbau in der region
tradition
[Musik]
die meisten westers sind älter als ihre
fahrer
wer eine besitzt sollte handwerklich
begabt sein es wird getüftelt und
gefachsimpelt
die vespa parade ist für viele der knapp
5000 besucher der höhepunkt auf dem
festivalgelände heißt es sehen und
gesehen werden
hier wird von früh bis spät ausgelassen
gefeiert konzerte heizen die stimmung an
[Musik]
und was natürlich nicht fehlen darf der
auftritt der wespe akrobatikgruppe aus
münchen eine der besten der welt
geleitet wird sie von robin d wie alias
mister vespa die disziplin hat ihre
anfänge in den 1950 er jahren die
münchner enthusiasten lassen die in
vergessenheit geratene kunstform seit
1995 wieder aufleben zum eigenen
vergnügen und dem des publikums
da waren heute richtig gut drauf und die
piste war ja ein bisschen buckelig
baumann gullydeckel dazwischen super wir
haben müssen wir sind super gefunden
habt ihr sie war akrobaten bei hinter
die kulissen machen sich nicht aus
[Applaus]
nächstes jahr gibt es die erste ausgabe
der vespa world days in asien und zwar
auf bali in indonesien
[Musik]